PALI BHAT: Today, we want to
talk about Cloud DevOps, right?
So when we talk about
DevOps, most people
think this, which
is, it's a great way
to connect the development
and operations teams
and bridge the gap.
Yes, this is true, but DevOps
is a lot more than just that.
Ultimately, what
DevOps can do is
get your business more agility.
It can bring feedback from
all of the downstream systems,
including your customers, back
into the development process
so that you can build great
solutions for your customers.
So as we think about
Cloud DevOps at Google,
there's three principles
that we keep in mind.
The first, of course,
is how do we increase
developer productivity, because
that's what we're all here for.
The second bit, which
is just as important,
is getting all of that
downstream feedback
and shifting it left so
developers have access to it
earlier in the cycle.
What this lets you do is
avoid those costly mistakes
and catch them
much, much sooner.
And the third piece,
which just as important,
is scaled operations.
What the cloud lets you do is
run your business at scale,
and Cloud DevOps
should enable that.
So we're going to talk a little
bit about each of these three
aspects, and then dive
into a fireside chat
as well in a little bit of time.
So first, let's talk
about how we increase
developer productivity.
As we talk to our customers,
the number one thing
we are hearing from
them is, yes, they've
looked at Cloud as a way
to lower their costs.
But they want a lot
more than just that.
They want greater agility
for their business.
And the way they want to do
this is by building cloud
native applications.
There's been a huge
surge of interest
in this, especially
around Kubernetes.
Unfortunately,
though, active teams
across a number of our
customers are still
working on traditional IDEs
that are optimized for local app
development.
Those run on premise.
And one of the
challenges with this
is as you use these local
environments to build cloud
native applications,
you frequently end up
with either more complexity
or errors that are
caught too late in the cycle.
So to solve this problem, we
announced Cloud Code yesterday.
And what Cloud Code
lets you do is rapidly
build debug and, of course,
to apply these Kubernetes
applications.
And the best part is you
can do all of that right
within the context of your
local development environment.
Think of this as a
power boost to your ID.
And we've shifted left
all of the complexity,
and we've abstracted it away
so you can actually just focus
on building cloud native apps.
To tell you more
about this, I want
to welcome on stage Jez Humble,
who's part of our developer
advocacy team.
Jez?
JEZ HUMBLE: So how many
people in this room
are building codes in nodes,
or Go, or Java, or Python?
OK, that's a lot of you.
Great.
How many people know how to
set up and manage a Kubernetes
cluster?
OK, that's also a lot of you.
That's great.
How many of you are
going to be working
on Kubernetes in the next year?
OK, almost everyone.
So that's great.
Kubernetes is the industry
standard infrastructure
for building cloud native apps.
But if you're
anything like me, you
might find Kubernetes
a little bit
intimidating to
set up and manage.
You might also worry about the
impacts on your productivity.
My favorite experience
as a developer
is being able to save in the
IDE, switch to the browser,
hit Refresh, and be able to
see pretty much instantly what
I did so that I can check
that I'm on the right track.
Microservices and
service-oriented architectures
also add complexity, and we want
to create a simple way for you
to stand up some subset of
your production environment
for development
purposes locally.
So today, we're going
to show you Cloud Code.
Cloud Code lets you develop
codes in VS code and IntelliJ
and get a seamless,
near-instant developer
experience that
mimics what you're
used to, that local
developer workflow.
So to show you that, we're
going to build and deploy
a simple distributed system.
This is a guest
book which is going
to talk to a microservice
that does translation
of the comments in the guest
book into different languages.
We're going to start off
by building and deploying
the translation microservices.
And Dan [INAUDIBLE]
here is going
to show us what that looks
like in Java using IntelliJ.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks, Jez.
Thanks, everyone, for coming.
Everyone here has heard of
terms like continuous delivery,
continuous integration,
continuous deployment.
Today, I'm going
to be showing how
to use Cloud Code for
IntelliJ to set up
a continuous development loop
where I can edit and save
my code locally, and it's
going to get deployed
and running inside of a
cloud Kubernetes cluster
inside of Google
Kubernetes Engine.
So right here, we have a cloud
native guest book application.
It's a very simple
Hello World service.
It was written in Java,
and it's printing out
hello world over HTTP.
Now we can see that
this is running
in our continuous
development loop.
So it's running here inside
of a remote Kubernetes
cluster in GKE.
Hit refresh, see that
we have the message.
I want to come in here
and change this message
and press Save.
And this is where the continuous
development loop kicks in.
So we can see here
below that Cloud Code
is watching this
code for changes,
detected that I saved this file,
and starts to automatically
rebuild, repackage, and
redeploy this up to GKE.
So this code has turned
into a container using
our Fast container
Builder called jib, which
knows how to optimally
rebuild and repackage
a Java application and get
it running in a container
registry.
Right, so this should just
be about to finish up here.
And we can refresh and
see our new message.
So we're able to
make this simple edit
and get it running
in GKE very quickly.
This is the basic app, though.
This isn't the
translation backend
that Jez talked about before.
So to turn this into a
translation back end,
I'm going to first add
some client libraries
and enable some APIs so that
we can use the Google Cloud
Translation API.
I'm going to do this using
another feature of Cloud Code.
I'm going to come in here
and add cloud libraries
and manage APIs.
I'll click that.
This is the translation backend.
So I'm going to click
here on Cloud Translation.
And there's a feature
to automatically enable
the API on GCP for us so we
don't have to leave the IDE.
I'll click Continue.
And this next dialog is a way
to have Cloud Code automatically
create a service
account in secret
so that you can talk
to this API since we're
running in Google
Kubernetes Engine,
though, we don't
need to use this.
I'll click OK.
And now Cloud Code
has automatically
added this dependency
to our application,
added it to our
palm.xml, and started
to rebuild and repackage
this again for us.
I'm going to switch this code
out for a translation back end.
And while that gets redeployed,
I'll explain how this works.
Here's the main function here.
It takes in some strings
over JSON on the HTTP
and first passes them
to the translation API
to detect the incoming language.
Next, based on what language
it is, we translate this
to both English and German.
And then at the bottom here,
we do some debug logging
to system.out.
Awesome.
This looks like
it's about finished.
And we can try it out here.
So I have some text
saved that we're going
to send in as a translation.
It's a couple strings.
So a couple strings
get passed in--
one in English-- hello world--
and a sentence in German.
We can see that these
are both translated back
into English and German.
And the final cool feature is
that cloud code automatically
streams these logs from
GKE back down to our IDE.
So we don't need to go anywhere
else to see the debug logging.
JEZ HUMBLE: So not only
did it deploy in Kubernetes
without you having
to do anything,
but it also streamed the logs
back into the IDE for you.
And that would have been
hard to do on your own.
It's great stuff.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
So we've got this simple
translation backend running.
Now We're going to work out
how to use this in a bigger
distributed application.
JEZ HUMBLE: Thanks
very much, Dan.
Woo!
Yeah, live demoing
is terrifying.
So obviously, in a
real system, we're
going to have more than
one service interacting.
So now we've got our
translation microservice live.
We're going to build
this guest book
and deploy the guest book
which is written in node.js.
And Vijay Vusirikala
is going to show us
how to do that using VS Code.
take it away, Vijay.
VIJAY VUSIRIKALA: Hi.
This is the-- hi. thanks, Jez.
This is the guest
book application
that Jez was
mentioning where users
can add guest book entries in
a language of their choice.
And we'll go out and integrate
this with the translation
service that Dan
has built to display
English and German translations
for these messages.
And I'll be using the cloud
code plugin for VS Code.
And I'll go through one cycle
of the inner development loop,
make four quick code
changes, deploy them
to the remote cluster, and
troubleshoot if required.
So the first change, I'll
make it in the display
template to add some style
sheets that are required.
Next, I'll go and add some
place holders for the English
and German translations.
Then we'll go to the
app.js file and tell it
that it can find the location
of our translation service
from the Kubernetes
environment variable.
Then we'll add the main logic
to call the translation service
for each of the
guest book entries.
It's a straightforward loop.
We'll add some error
handling as well.
And then finally, we'll publish
the location of our translation
end point.
And then we'll go ahead
and save our changes.
And the continuous
deployment has been
monitoring for your changes.
And once it's detected
them, it's packaged them
and send it over to the
remote cluster for deployment.
And as you can
see, the deployment
has already finished.
And let's reload this.
So there you go.
We have our English and
German translations.
That does not look like German.
Does it, Jez?
JEZ HUMBLE: [SPEAKING GERMAN]
VIJAY VUSIRIKALA: OK.
So let's go see
what's happening.
So the logs that were
in the remote cluster
are streamed directly
back into your ID.
So you don't have to go
around hunting for them.
So from the logs, we can
see that the German messages
are indeed coming back from
the translation service.
So that service communication
is working fine.
So it must be something going
on with our application.
So why don't we
just try to debug?
Let's set a breakpoint here.
And let us start our debugger.
And the debugger attaches
against a running process
in the remote cluster.
So let's go ahead and
reload our application.
Boom-- the debugger
breakpoint has been hit,
and we didn't have
to do anything.
This is against
the remote cluster.
JEZ HUMBLE: That's amazing.
So we're debugging using
the regular IDE debugger
in the Kubernetes cluster.
We didn't have to create
any launch configurations,
write any YAML, do
any port forwarding.
It just work from
within the IDE.
That's awesome stuff.
VIJAY VUSIRIKALA: And this
is a fully featured debugger.
You saw me stepping through it.
You have the watch variables.
You've got the [INAUDIBLE].
You can even inspect
the variables.
So from this, I can look at
the temporary translations area
that the code is building.
And I can see that the
German translation is
reaching my application code.
So maybe we're missing some
kind of assignment statement
somewhere.
So let's go ahead to our
debug console and hard wire
one of these assignments
and see if it gets
reflected in our application.
So we hardware for
one of the entries.
So-- oops-- and let's let
our debugger run through.
And there we see.
The entry that we
changed is being
reflected in our application.
JEZ HUMBLE: And
once again, that's
changing the state
of the live system
from within the debugger--
cool stuff.
VIJAY VUSIRIKALA: So looks like
we're missing an assignment
statement somewhere.
There it is.
So let's go ahead and fix it.
And let's save our changes
and stop the debugger.
And Cloud Code would have
picked up these changes
and would have already
started packaging them
and started deploying
to the remote cluster.
And as soon as it
finishes deployment,
we can reload the page.
It should--
JEZ HUMBLE: Obviously, the
IDE takes its time, especially
when there's a demo.
That's a built-in feature.
If you're demoing, it
adds a special lag just
to make your life difficult.
VIJAY VUSIRIKALA: So
it will reload the page
with the right entries.
So what you just saw was one
cycle of the inner development
loop.
We made some changes.
We deployed them.
We debugged them,
and you didn't have
to touch any Kubernetes
configurations yourself.
Cloud Code handled all that
for you in the background.
JEZ HUMBLE: Cool.
Thanks very much, Vijay.
VIJAY VUSIRIKALA: Thank you.
JEZ HUMBLE: OK, so once
you've got your service live
in production, obviously
you have a whole team
that takes care of it.
And Ben is going to be
talking about SRE later
on in this segment.
So one of the key
concepts of SRE
is SLOs, or Service
Level Objectives.
And these are targets for the
health of your application
that represents something
a user would experience,
not a proxy variable like
CPU usage or memory usage.
And once we have
SLOs, what happens
is our application breaks
them, and we get woken up
at 4 o'clock in the morning.
So I've been woken up at
4 o'clock in the morning
because our application
has fallen below its SLOs,
and I'm going to ping
Christie Wilson, who
is on call for this app.
And she's going
to work out what's
going on so that we
can remediate and get
everything working again.
Over to you, Christie.
CHRISTIE WILSON: All
right, so it's 4:00 AM.
I'm on call, and
I've been paged.
I need to figure out what's
going wrong in production
and fix it as
quickly as possible.
So to do that, I'm going to
use Cloud Service Mesh, or CSM.
So CSM is currently in
alpha, and it requires Istio.
But out of the box,
I can take a look
at things about my running
services like the metrics.
I can look at the logs, and
I can look at other telemetry
data as well.
And I can create
my own custom SLOs.
So here, we can see
that I've already
defined one for 95th
percentile latency,
and it's being violated.
And since I'm looking at
the front end service,
I have a pretty good guess
that the reason I was paged
is because the front end
service is overloaded.
So I need to mitigate
this as fast as possible
so I can get back to bed.
So to do that, I'm
going to use Cloud Code.
So Cloud Code can be used
by all kinds of engineers,
whether you're
wearing your developer
hat or your operations hat.
And so what I'm going
to do is I'm actually
going to take a look directly
at the production cluster
in the Cluster Explorer.
Now, obviously,
not all developers
should have access to this,
but I'm on call, so I do.
So in the Cluster
Explorer, I can
start looking at what's
going on in production.
I can see my deployments.
They're all green.
And I can start diving
into individual pods.
I can look at the
containers in those pods,
and I can see details
like what environment
variables they're running
with, what the status is.
And I can even get the logs
from my production cluster
right in my IDE.
And if I want to, I can
even connect a terminal
and start executing commands
in my production containers.
So one thing that I'm
noticing as I look at this
is that our overloaded service
only has one replica running.
And since it's overloaded,
I'm thinking maybe
a way I can work around
this is to increase
the number of replicas.
So to do that, I'm going
to use this edit icon here,
and I'm actually going to bring
up the production configuration
right in my IDE
and make a change.
So I want to increase the
number of replicas from 1 to 10.
But I'm tired, so I made a typo,
and I put the value in wrong.
But fortunately,
the IDE has my back.
So it's telling me, because
it's aware of the schema,
that the type is wrong here
and this should be an integer.
So I can make the
change I meant to.
And because it is
aware of the schema,
the IDE, can give me
IntelliSense and show me
what values are valid at this
point in the configuration.
So let's go ahead and save that.
And the IDE prompts
me to warn me
that it's about to apply
this live to a production
cluster which, yes,
I did want to do.
And in the Cluster
Explorer I can refresh.
And I can see that
Kubernetes is immediately
doing what it does best and
scaling out the 10 replicas
that I requested.
JEZ HUMBLE: So any
ops people, SREs,
or sysadmins are probably
having a mild heart
attack at the moment
watching Christie
change the state of a
live production cluster
from her IDE.
And in fairness,
that wasn't a feature
we'd originally planned.
We got feedback from
our early access users
that they wanted
this functionality.
And in fairness,
it's super useful
if you're managing a dev
cluster or a test cluster.
It's really, really helpful.
However, in real
life, what we want
to do is make this change
to version control,
push it out through a
deployment pipeline.
This is the paradigm
known as infrastructure
as code or GitOps.
So Christie, how
would we do that?
CHRISTIE WILSON: Well,
let's take a look
at the files in version control.
So this is the deployment
in version control.
And as you can see, because
of my emergency change,
it has fallen out of
sync with production.
So I'm going to make
the change here.
But before I do
that, I can show you
some other Cloud Code features.
If you've been working
with Kubernetes,
you've probably
noticed that you end up
dealing with a lot of YAML.
But having YAML support
directly in your IDE
can make that a
lot less painful.
For example, if I'm looking
at this Mongo deployment
and say I want to know what
the value is of this secret,
instead of having to dig
around in the YAML in my repo
and figure out where
that secret lives,
I can actually just
peek at it directly
and see what the value is.
And these base64
encoded strings,
I can just hover
over them and see
what the plain text values are.
JEZ HUMBLE: I just
want to emphasize,
Christie did not
choose that password.
Christie would never do that.
CHRISTIE WILSON: Yeah,
I'm going to have
some words with some
people after this, I think.
So what I'm going to do now
is open the configuration
and make the change
to 10 replicas.
So now, I would
commit this, push it,
and open a pull request.
And then Cloud
Build would kick in.
And it would do all
the things that we
want to do to properly land
this change in production,
like running vulnerability
scanning, tests, et cetera.
JEZ HUMBLE: Thank you
so much, Christie.
[APPLAUSE]
And so this is what it would
look like in Google Cloud
Platform in Cloud Build,
seeing the builds that
have gone through into
prods from version control.
So once we've got
everything working again,
we're going to go back
to sleep, hopefully,
and get up in the
morning and work out
what the actual problem was
in the app that was causing
that performance degradation.
We can use Stackdriver
Profiler to do that.
Stackdriver Profiler
is really powerful.
Some of our customers have
seen double digit reductions
in CPU usage as a
result of using.
It and it's generally
available as of Tuesday.
So today, we showed
you Cloud Code.
Cloud Code lets see you
develop, deploy, and debug
your Kubernetes-based
applications
directly from within your IDE.
And it doesn't just
work against GKE.
It works against any
Kubernetes cluster.
Whether that's local, in a data
center, another cloud provider,
Cloud Code will talk to
any Kubernetes cluster.
You can download the code
that we've showed you today.
It's available in nodes, in
Go, in Java, and in Python.
Start playing with
that right now.
And we really hope you're as
excited as we are about this
powerful functionality, and we
cannot wait to see what you do
with it.
Thanks very much for your time.
Back to you, Pali.
PALI BHAT: Thank you, Jez.
That was super
exciting to see and one
of the great ways you can
increase developer productivity
while you're building cloud
native Kubernetes applications.
So let's talk about the next
thing, which is shifting left.
And the purpose of shifting
left, as we discussed earlier,
is to help connect all of
the downstream feedback
to your developers and
to your development teams
so you can catch those costly
errors much, much sooner.
This could be everything
from enforcing
coding guidelines to getting
operational metrics earlier
in the cycle.
And of course, one of the most
important things you want to do
is catch those security errors
very, very early in the process
because those can
be really costly.
To tell you a little
bit more about how
we're thinking about
shifting security left
and give you a
practitioner's view of it,
I want to welcome Mike
Berry from ANZ onstage.
MIKE BERRY: So good
morning, everyone.
My name is Mike.
And yes, I work at a bank.
The ANZ Bank has been operating
in Australia for the past 180
years, and every day, we
look after the details
and information of
millions of customers.
And we look after billions
of dollars of transactions.
So as you can imagine, security
is very important to the way
that we operate.
Now, banking over those 180
years has changed considerably.
It used to be about how secure
your vault was in your branch,
and that was security.
But now we have more
things to think about.
In particular, today we're
going to talk about security
of our services and
applications as they're
running in the cloud.
Now we have
vulnerability scanning.
So we're going to
talk about two things.
The first,
vulnerability scanning--
when you're running a
vulnerability scanning,
the question is, how
are you doing it?
So today, do you have--
in the audience here, do you
have vulnerability scanning
of some kind that you're
running right now?
Who has their hands up?
Yeah, we have-- all right, we
have vulnerability scanners
out here.
This is very good.
My question is, when
you run these scans,
what do you do with them?
Do you go, oh, I've
got this scan run,
and now I'm going
to raise a ticket.
Or I've got this report,
and I'll look into that
or raise a risk or--
do these things last for
a day or for a few days?
Or sometimes, you're
like, oh, my goodness.
We haven't run this
for a few weeks.
And now we're getting to
the end of the project.
Quick, run a scan.
See how it goes.
And then, oh, my
goodness, we're going
to spend days going through
these vulnerabilities doing
patching, doing
retesting, doing re-fixes.
And then finally,
it's all sorted out.
And so that kind of
approach to your security
can really slow down your
work and impede your velocity.
So what we're doing
now at the ANZ
is we're using the vulnerability
scanner in Google Cloud.
But we're using it in
every build that we do.
So we see here we
have our source code.
Our source code moves
into Cloud Build
and does all the usual
things we do in a build.
But at the same time, we
run that vulnerability scan.
And what happens is if that
vulnerability scan fails,
then instantly, we
have a red build.
And a developer can go
in, have a look at that,
find out what is the issue.
And it will highlight
for you the severity.
It will highlight for you which
package is impacted by that.
And you can go in and you can
do the patching or remediation,
whatever is required.
And you fix that.
So you find that problem.
You fix that one small problem.
And then that's resolved.
Run the build again.
Everything's green and
everything's fine again.
And so instead of taking
this huge amount of pain
down the end of weeks of
your work and slowing down,
we just take these little
increments along the way.
When you find these
things as they occur,
we fix them straightaway.
And that helps us keep that
velocity moving as we're
working in our development.
So that's one way that
we're approaching security.
The other one is
binary authorization.
So we've looked at kind of the
left side and that CI process.
Now we need to move
on to the deployments
so as we move our
deployment through,
how are we doing the
enforcement of this security?
Because you may have lots
of security applications
because that's the--
when we scan things
for vulnerabilities,
that's one process we have.
But we have lots of
other security tools,
lots of other test processes.
Maybe you have
performance testing.
How are you getting
that information
and making sure that it
applies to that binary
that you're moving into your
production environments?
Because if you have security
and you have lots of reports
and you leave those
reports stacked up
in a big pile on your desk,
that's not helping anyone.
What you need to do with that
information is enforce that.
And so binary authorization is
a way to force your security.
Now I will talk
about a little bit,
but maybe what we'll do first
is we'll do a little demo
and have a look at
how this applies.
All right, there's no
shortage of laptops today.
All right, here you go.
So this is a simple demo.
What we've got here
is my two images
in my Container Registry.
And now by looking
at those images,
you tell me which one has
passed all of my testing and all
my criteria and
which one has not.
And the answer is
you can't tell.
Just say no.
But we're going to find out.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to grab the
business processor,
and we're going to deploy it.
And one button deploys.
Yes, and we're going
to hit Refresh.
We're going to look
at our cluster.
And oh, my goodness--
that's the wrong one.
So what we see here
is that this is
being forbidden by a policy
that says this image has not
been approved.
And so the way this works,
binary authorization sees
your image, comes in, and it
looks for an attachment that's
attached to this.
So that's a way to attach
a certificate to say,
this has passed our policies.
And we have a
certificate to prove
that this image is OK with us.
And in the case of
this particular image,
that image is not
OK, and it should not
be deployed to our environment.
Now, don't worry.
We're not going to
leave it with red.
We're going to have a look
at Business Orchestrator.
That's our other image.
I'm going to press a
button, Orchestrator.
I'm going to press that button.
Magic is going to happen.
Yes.
Hit Refresh.
It's a perfect demo.
So green lights, everybody.
We're all happy because
this image actually
has that certificate
attached to it.
Binary authorization reads it.
It says this has
passed your policies.
You are cleared all
the way through.
And you've got a big
green light for that.
And so the way it
works is imagine this.
You have an internal audit team.
And they come to
you, and they say,
we need to understand
your controls.
We need to understand
your policies.
So what we're going to
do with you is we're
going to set you a meeting
for a couple of hours.
And we're going to read
documentation together.
And we're going to understand
how your policies work.
You're like, well, that sounds
like a lot of fun, guys.
But how about we do a demo?
I've got an image here.
This image has been
approved by nobody.
It's been tested by nobody.
And really, I don't even
know where it came from.
And I'm going to deploy
it to production.
Then you jump into production.
You press the Deploy button.
And you show your
audit team, look,
this cannot be
deployed to production.
We don't just talk
about security here.
We enforce our security.
And so we make sure
these things move through
because they're approved.
Now, when I've done
this demo, I just
did that with the one
tester, the one policy.
But you can have a
multitude of policies
that you might want to apply and
do that for different clusters
depending on how you set
up your organization.
So imagine in one
cluster, you're like,
all that has to happen here
is we need a peer review.
That's all we need.
You can deploy it
in this cluster.
The production cluster,
maybe you want a peer review.
Maybe you want to pass a
certain phase of testing.
And maybe you want to add
to that there's a team,
or even a person if you choose
to, that is a part of this.
So if we go back
to the slides now,
we can see on the left side,
we have our vulnerability
scanning.
We're testing these
things straight away.
And then as they move
through to deployments,
we're making sure that we have
just those trusted images that
move through and they're
deployed to our engine.
And because this is all a
pipeline, so we have security.
But it's moving through with
automation and with the speed
that we have available from
this automated pipeline.
And so at the ANZ
Bank, that's how
we're applying these two
principles to make sure
that we move with security and
all the things that we need
but moving that security forward
with speed and reliability.
So thank you.
Back to you, Pali.
PALI BHAT: So we talked about
how we can increase developer
productivity with Cloud Code.
We then talked about
shifting left, especially
on security with Cloud Build.
Now let's talk about how you
can scale your operations.
This is one of the huge benefits
of Cloud and why all of you
are adopting cloud today.
So as we think about
scaled operations,
my mind goes back to
Google because we've
got eight products with
over 1 billion users each.
And as you saw during
the keynote yesterday,
Urs shared a study
that showed that of all
of the major clouds, Google
Cloud was the most reliable.
And much of that is because
we have internally in Google
an amazing SRE team that
helps us scale and operate
all of these Google
products and, of course,
Google Cloud as well.
And for the last 15
plus years, there's
been one person at
the head of that team.
So I'd love to welcome on
board Ben Treynor, who's
been leading our SRE team
for the last 15 years,
for a fireside chat.
BEN TREYNOR: No pressure, then.
PALI BHAT: So Ben,
we talked about all
of these billion user services.
BEN TREYNOR: Yes.
PALI BHAT: I wonder how
many folks in the audience
are using billion user
services every day.
BEN TREYNOR: Well, I suspect,
you know, probably a few.
But it's also-- it's one
of those interesting myths.
You say, well, SRE,
isn't that for only the
really, really,
really big services?
And I think we maybe have
an audience-- an opportunity
to talk about that a bit.
But certainly, you know, I
started the SRE team a little,
as you say, 15 and
1/2 years ago now.
Google was not that
big at that point.
And in particular, some of the
services that we were running
were actually fairly
modest in size.
And we've found that we have a
set of principles and practices
that we can use across services
at pretty much any scale.
And we found that they helped.
PALI BHAT: Yeah.
So Ben, as you think
about these SRE practices,
could you share a little bit
more about what those are?
BEN TREYNOR: Yeah, absolutely.
And I think you have a slide up
here that talks about a study
that Forester did recently
about SRE practices
and said, essentially, you know,
can these be used by anybody,
or do you need this
huge monolith of code
and engineering support?
And they found that roughly
half of them did not need this.
But let me talk about a few of
the SRE practices that I think
are usable and applicable
to pretty much anybody
who's running a service.
The first is one that we talked
about a bit earlier, which
is having SLOs.
And SLO is a pretty dry term.
It stands for a Service
Level Objective,
and, you know, the
number of people
who get excited about service
level objectives, it's modest,
let me assure you.
But what SLOs really
mean is you want
to be able to measure what your
actual end user experience is,
and you want to have an
opinion about what performance
would be sufficient
for most of your users
to like your product.
We actually internally
call them happy SLOs.
It sounds very cheery.
But it's a very
simple concept, right?
Measure your application
the way your end user
sees it and have an opinion
about what the end user would
need to see to be happy.
Sounds really easy.
It's actually usually
fairly hard in practice.
Most applications don't actually
instrument what the user sees.
They instrument some things
that are along the way and say,
well, good enough, right?
And what we've found in SRE and
in running Google services is
actually, that last
mile of instrumenting
the common activities that
users are actually doing
is really important.
Oftentimes, the behavior that
they see isn't what you think,
and the instrumentation that
you do on intermediate steps
doesn't actually tell you
about some of the problems
that you've got.
And so I like to
differentiate and say,
like, there's black
box monitoring,
and black box monitoring is
what your happy SLOs should
eventually should be looking at.
Now, as we saw earlier,
if you're on call
and the monitor says
something's wrong,
you want a little more
information than that.
And so in addition
to that, you know,
you'll clearly have SLOs for
internal microservices and SLOs
for intermediate
steps and so on.
But the most important thing is
instrumenting the end result,
because after all, that's the
only thing your user sees.
And really, it's the only
thing that they care about.
And that's something that
you can do right away.
In fact, really, it's
easier, trust me,
to do when the application is
small than when it gets bigger.
So another concept that we use
that really sort of applies
to everyone is this
concept of error budgets.
And an error budget sounds
like a very sort of odd thing.
If you've read the SRE book,
it probably seems less odd.
But it's an important concept
in site reliability, which
is that our goal is actually
not perfect availability
because, number one, right,
your users are using a device--
maybe a laptop maybe a
phone, maybe a computer--
which is not 100% reliable.
They're communicating
with your service
over a network which
is not 100% reliable,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And so the difference
between, let's say,
five nines and perfection
is probably not
distinguishable by your
users because there are so
many other things in
the path that will also
break their experience.
But the engineering cost of the
difference between five nines
and perfect is immense, and its
drag on your feature velocity
is immense.
And ultimately, you're
running a business.
You're running a service.
And so these two
basic goals, I want
to service that's
reliable but I also
want high feature velocity--
I want to be able to launch
new things that my users want--
is really important.
And error budgets is the concept
that lets you bridge those two.
And it's really fairly simple.
If your availability
target is four nines,
then your error budget
is that last 0.01%.
And you can spend it
silly errors, right?
Pushes that shouldn't
have been made,
features that
basically don't work.
Or you can spend it taking
calculated risk, right?
Exposing a new feature
to 0.01% or 0.1%
of your users for 10 minutes
and measuring the result.
And if you have happy SLOs, you
know whether it worked or not.
This lets you have very
fast feature velocity
because you can
take a small risk,
look at its effect on
your SLO, and decide
whether you want to make
that a larger risk or not.
And it also helps the SRE
team or your operations team
agree with your
development team.
Should we do this?
Well, are we out of budget?
Yes or no?
If we're not out of
budget, let's go ahead
and launch it, right?
We have budget to spare.
And if we are out
of budget, well, OK.
Data says we're not making
sufficiently prudent or careful
choices and we should hold
back and spend a bit more time
on availability.
Blameless
Post-Mortems-- somebody
mentioned it
earlier when I think
there was a hiccup in a demo.
This is an SRE practice
that's actually pretty
easy for everyone to adopt.
And it's not a
complicated idea--
again, in theory, harder
to implement in practice.
But the basic idea here is
you've hired good people.
You have a recruiting
process to identify
people who are intelligent
and smart, well-intentioned.
And despite all of that, despite
these people doing their best,
something went wrong.
Look at how your system
works and figure out
how you'll make it less
likely for the system
to break, easier for the people
who are looking after it to fix
it when it breaks,
and make those
the goals of a
post-mortem, right?
Figure out how to make
it more likely to succeed
next time despite the
fact that there are going
to be people working
on this who are
intelligent and
well-intentioned and imperfect.
And then finally, capping
and eliminating toil--
this is actually--
it's better if you
start this at a small scale.
But this is the idea that
every system, as time passes,
requires more and
more things that
need to be done by hand because,
you know, we were in a rush.
You needed to get that
feature out the door,
and there were a few bits that
weren't fully buttoned down.
But we can deal with them later.
My experience is there is
never the later, right?
There is only the now.
And by the time you
finish that feature,
there will be the
next round of features
that you're already
slightly behind.
So you know, get
rid of that fantasy
and instead say, toil, you
know, human work to do something
where that work does not
make tomorrow better.
You'll just have to do it again.
Toil is another budget
that you have to manage.
And in SRE at Google, we
say toil is capped at 50%.
You can't have the team spending
more than half of its time
on sort of non-repeatable
human actions
to support various interesting
features and snowflakes and so
on.
And the rest of
the time has to be
spent making the service
better, building production
infrastructure, et cetera.
And once you view
it as a budget,
then you ask the
question of where
am I going to spend
my toil budget.
And it'll be on the things that
are brand new and hard where
you don't really know exactly
how to do them automatically
yet.
And then you'll have a fraction
of your development time
that's spent implementing
and deploying
projects that get rid
of toil in the places
where it's now easier.
And that cycle kind
of continues forever.
But it's important to keep
this as an explicit budget,
and it's important
to actually watch
to make sure your teams don't
spend too much of their time
on toil because there's
only two options, right?
Option number one, your
service is not successful.
Your business goes under and
none of this matters, right?
Option two, your
service is successful.
It grows, and toil
typically grows
roughly linearly with the
size of your business.
So if your team is 50%
occupied with toil right now
and not doing anything to fix
it and your business doubles,
guess what, right?
You're going to be hiring
a bunch more SREs--
not a good plan.
So this is, in some
ways, a plan for success,
and it involves a certain
amount of continuous investment.
But it absolutely
is the right path
if you plan to be successful.
PALI BHAT: So Ben, as
I talk to customers,
the first thing they tell me is,
like, they love this concept.
They want to implement all this.
But they're worried it will
take them a lot of money,
cost them a lot of money, or
they probably need new people.
So how do you respond to them?
BEN TREYNOR: First, I laugh.
Ha ha ha.
So you know, as I tell
people, I'm actually
a software engineer, right?
This is the first
operationally oriented role
I've had in my entire career.
I started out in
enterprise software,
interestingly, at Oracle when
they were a little 400 person
company.
Who knew?
And you don't actually
need new people to do SRE
or to do DevOps or to
do these practices.
In fact, you should have
people who are engineers,
and who consider themselves
software engineers
and who will be
bored to tears if you
ask them to do the same
thing over and over again
because they have the right
mindset to say, how do I make
a machine do all of this boring
work, this repetitive work,
this vigilance work that people
are actually quite bad at,
so that I can get on to
doing something that's
more interesting?
And that's a great motivation.
These practices then
give them guidance
on how to do that effectively.
You definitely don't
need new tooling.
I mean, all of the things that
we've described here-- like,
what you have now in cloud
is way better than what we
had in SRE in the early days.
And in fact, a number of the
systems that we have here
have been influenced by
what people have discovered
in DevOps over the years.
And yes, this isn't just
for cloud native, right?
These same rules of
physics essentially
apply to any system.
I will say that services
that are running in the cloud
definitely have it easier
because as you've just shown,
you've built a
bunch of the things
into cloud that we had
to build ourselves.
But the open source community,
if you're still running things
in-house, the open
source community
now offers a lot of these
systems for you as well.
And I would definitely
take advantage of them.
PALI BHAT: So as I talk
to these customers again,
the other common
thing I hear is, hey,
we've already got a DevOps team.
BEN TREYNOR: Yep.
PALI BHAT: And so do we need to
now create a second SRE team?
BEN TREYNOR: So the
good news is no.
I've gotten this question
a few times over the years.
I coined SRE back in 2004, and
there was DevOps at that time
as well.
But both of them have
emerged as industry,
let's call them,
tracks since then.
But SRE and DevOps
are not different.
SRE is a particular
instantiation of ops
but nothing more.
And if you actually
go through and read
what the different
branches of DevOps
have to say about how
systems should be managed,
how services should be
monitored, et cetera,
they're very similar
to what SRE does.
I simply would say SRE is a
more specific implementation
of this general class of DevOps.
It's worked well for us.
It doesn't necessarily have
to be exactly the recipe
that everyone follows.
It's not the only
path to success.
But I would say these two are
very much complementary ideas.
And in some places I expect,
the folks in the broader DevOps
community absolutely
will come up
with a superior approach, in
which case we will adopt it.
And we have written now
two books in the SRE team
covering our specific
implementation.
And again, I think those are
useful for folks to understand
what we did and how we did it.
They don't necessarily have
to be adopted wholesale
by other teams.
PALI BHAT: Yeah.
So Ben, could you actually
share with the audience
what are like a few things
that they could just
start doing tomorrow--
BEN TREYNOR: Yes.
PALI BHAT: --right?
To adopt SRE.
BEN TREYNOR: So interestingly,
when we wrote the first SRE
book, that was one of the
principal questions we got
back is, OK, this
all sounds great,
and these are
interesting stories.
But how do I turn
this into practice?
And so we wrote the
second book in part
to answer that question, and if
you have the time and energy,
I'd definitely
recommend reading it.
We put a fair bit into it.
But let me give you three
that you can do today
or immediately that are three
of the most important practices,
I think.
The first is to
actually write down
those happy SLOs
we talked about.
It is perhaps unsurprising
but still surprising
how few SLOs actually
get defined and monitored
and how often what you find
is what we've monitored
is the thing that's
convenient versus the thing
the customer cares about.
And then over a series of
outages and post-mortems,
you eventually migrate.
So you can skip that whole
step, right, and go directly
to the great end result if you
take the time to write down
the SLOs that if you just barely
were meeting those things,
most of your customers
would be happy.
And then dog food them, right?
If you use your
product internally,
and you should, try making
your internal instance
of your service operate where
it's just barely meeting
those SLOs you just wrote and
see whether your internal users
are happy.
And if everyone's more
or less, yeah, you know,
seems slightly sluggish but
it's OK, you've got a good SLO.
If everyone grabs their
torches and pitchforks
and comes to your door, you
may want to revise, right?
And secondly, we
talked about toil.
Toil is-- it's like
technical debt,
right, except it's
much easier to measure.
And my recommendation is
look at your sources of toil
and just pick the one that's
the highest ROI, right?
It's easy to fix.
It occupies a lot
of people's time
maybe because it
gets done a lot.
And start an engineering
project to actually fix that.
Carve out folks' time
because it gives you
this great experience
of now we've
spent n months of engineering,
and we've gotten rid
of n years per year of toil.
OK, now I see how
the system works,
and we can have a regular review
and sort of look for our toil
and decide which ones
are worth eliminating.
And that get you
started on a path
to avoid what we call
ops overload, which
you don't want to be in.
And then finally, everyone
has some production incident,
right, whether it was an actual
full blown outage or just
something that didn't go well.
Conduct a blameless post-mortem.
Try the approach
of saying, let me
assume that although humans
will always make mistakes,
I'm not going to focus on
that because I don't actually
know how to fix that
in the real world.
But I can fix how
the system works.
And conduct a post-mortem
where the conclusions are,
we should fix the
following things
in the system to make
it less likely to fail,
more likely to provide
good diagnostic information
when it does fail, make
the failure less severe,
make the failure
shorter, and see
if you like that result because
my prediction is you will.